so what I want to highlight for us is
the important lease that we can use here
to work out what's going on okay so for
starters I want you to look over here at
the first object we measured I'm going
to put a link like that you see that can
you make it out of the screen that's
what Hubble can you see that no man okay
actually maybe I'll do it in white maybe
what will be easier for you how about
that yeah you see that yeah so that
length I think we measure there's what
10 so that so I'm just going to make
myself a space it's a ride on here I'll
give you a heading in a second though in
some senses it's still part of the same
thing okay so you've got about 10
centimeters there but then the next
thing we measured was this shadow right
so it's coming off like this and what
was that with at 12 12 right yep
okay so see the lines the actual stuff
that I'm drawing on that's the part
that's most important to you okay so
I've got that and if you connect these
together they make a triangle we don't
need the whole triangle there but we are
comparing shapes after all so if you
wanted you could use Pythagoras work out
how long it is but you don't need to
okay right so you can draw out a
triangle just like that with a with the
two measures on there ten and twelve
then you want to come over here and say
okay I have a new triangle here I've got
this length which I don't know and we
didn't actually go and measure that and
if physically we can but maybe in some
situations we can you got that length up
there and then you've got this other leg
that we actually you said you measured
the distal one right over there that one
which one okay I'll put it back okay so
I'm gonna make my triangle over here
okay what was what
the twelve I don't think so yeah that's
right yeah that's exactly okay so you
can see we have I think Holly you said
it was thirty seven didn't you yeah
thirty-seven no and here's the wonderful
thing right where imagine is situation
where this are the side we're talking
about you mean you mean this one right
this one over here yeah know which one
you talk about you means that one in the
air this one which other side do you
need all right
that's why I thought in the first place
but it doesn't matter all too much this
should be pretty close to each other
it's okay it's alright don't get hung up
on the details okay so this hide over
here I don't know what it is so I'm
gonna call it H all right so you can see
what I've established here is a pair of
similar triangles now they have to be
similar to each other because what's
happening is you've got the source of
light coming from the same direction
right you see that let me obviously put
this in red okay so you have got those
diagrams there so you've got you don't
have the photo in the way so you don't
need to do this next thing I'm about to
do I'm going to take all of this stuff
here and that's the important that's the
important part that I can actually do
some math with right so head down here
yeah it's okay
that covered there we go I've got to get
rid of that and that done okay
so now now you can see this is just like
one of the questions we did before yeah
let's think about it I told you four
steps four steps what's the first one I
know because we're looking at them at an
angle but that's fine that's okay
what's the first step before that before
the corresponding that's the second one
okay what do I want to know and that's
the H over here okay so the first thing
I'm going to do I've got some space over
here is I'm gonna write that pronumeral
master okay then what happens next I ok
decide the lathe that corresponds to
that age this is 10 right now I can do I
could have started with this one and
then 10 over H but do you see because
what I want is H I need H on the top
eventually so I might as well just write
on the top of the first time as you'll
see there'll only be one thing I have to
do if I write the in this order okay so
I've got the length I want the leg that
corresponds to step three I've got you
can see my error right I've got the
other pair this pair of legs and that
gives me this relationship yeah so 37
over 12 okay so can someone tell me what
370 over 12 actually comes out so you
can I get one decimal place I multiplied
across I didn't yep yeah can someone can
someone get me a Kevin 30.8 okay now
interestingly I'm pretty sure all of us
know that's not 30.8 right that's not
thirty point now part of the reason why
is we we had a discussion of that and we
just kind of glossed over because we
wanted to do it quickly for sake of time
where do you measure that shadow is that
accurate one of the tricky things if I
come back to the original photo right
where is that shadow ending it's
actually not necessarily that clear yeah
well that's exactly what it does when
Wyatt is coming from multiple sources
launches from one okay but as a proof of
concept this is the whole idea right i
this is what this next part of the
exercises are bad about apply it to
actual situations like this where you
can measure things that can't be
measured by climbing up some stupid
insane tower right it's like we just
need no bad shatter and that's really
easy to measure okay